joining us now from the White House is
John Kirby he's the national security
council's coordinator for strategic
Communications Admiral Kirby we thank
you for your time this morning because
all of a sudden Sudan is front page news
people are thinking what's happening
there did the U.S government have some
inkling that things were spinning out of
control and I asked this because the
daring rescue plan seemed to come
together very very quickly it was only a
week ago Saturday Gail that the fighting
really broke out in Khartoum and became
so deadly and so violent and So within
that course of a week we moved from
again just urging both sides to abide by
a ceasefire which of course we still do
to feeling like it wasn't safe enough
for our diplomats and our Embassy to
stay manned there and operating and so
we move them out it is still very
dangerous those images that you just
showed I think clearly demonstrate the
level of violence and the activity
inside cartoon which is why we're
advising all Americans those who didn't
take the warning to get out to shelter
in place to stay to stay safe this is
not the time to be moving around the
city
I know Mr Kirby those images are
terrifying do you have any numbers on
how many Americans still remain and what
are their options of people that say I
want to get out and I want to go now
yeah great question Gail look and there
are there are thousands of of American
citizens that live and work in Sudan the
vast majority of them are dual Nationals
they have citizenship in the United
States as well as Sudan they grew up in
Sudan families are there businesses are
there uh and they don't have any
interest in in leaving now we do know
there are some American citizens those
that work for partner agencies of ours
like for the implementing partners of
usaid or teach at the American school
that we're in touch with that may want
to leave and I can tell you that several
dozen right now are part of this U.N
Convoy that's making its way to Port
Sudan right now over land and the United
States military is providing OverWatch
through unmanned assets to watch over
that Convoy to make sure that we're uh
that we're being be able to see whatever
security problems they might face and of
course we're looking at putting Naval
ass Assets in the Red Sea near Port
Sudan to help with any evacuation or
assistance that American citizens might
need we're going to do everything we can
to help guide people get them the
information they need to get out safely
but it is not safe right now for another
evacuation attempt that would actually
put Americans in more danger not less
uh Admiral it's Tony decopo I wanted to
get one question in about the 21 year
old national Guardsman accused of
leaking classified documents to his
buddies and online gaming platform
Discord we knew that he'd been doing it
October of 2022 or accused of and now
there's reporting suggesting that it
might have gone back as far as February
of 2022 raising the question do we know
how many documents are actually out
there how big of a leak we're dealing
with the truth is Tony that we don't uh
and that's obviously deeply concerning
to all of us we want to get uh as great
a grasp on the scope of the universe of
documents that are out there so we can
do a proper National Security assessment
of exactly what damage might be done but
we don't know and that's why we're fully
cooperating with the Department of
Justice as they work through a criminal
investigation it's also why the Air
Force and the Department of Defense are
working really hard to again try to get
a better grip on on exactly what's out
there and what damage might be done by
those documents being in the public
domain
and that Guardsman has not entered a
plea as of yet John Kirby thank you very
much for the clarity this morning yes
sir